حراره نيران تلك المدافع في اوكرانيا لم
تغير ملامح هذه الارض فقط لكنها غيرت ايضا
وضعيه الدول في اوروبا فبدلا من فرنسا
والمانيا والتاثير السياسي والاقتصادي
والعسكري القوي لكل منهما سطعت بولندا
ودول البلطيق
من اندلاع الحرب شكل الدعم لاوكرانيا
معضله اساسيه بولندا ودول البلطيق مثلت
القوه الدافعه الاساسيه وراء الدعم مقابله
حاله تشبه الشلل انتاج الزعماء اوروبا
التقليديين فرنسا والمانيا
بعد شهور من الجدل لارسال الدبابات
الغربيه الاوكرانيا حسمت الضغوط المبذوله
من شرق ووسط اوروبا قرارات الدعم العسكري
لكييف حيث شكلت بولندا احدى جماعات الضغط
الرئيسيه لمحاوله اقناع المانيا المتردده
بارسال الدبابات الى اوكرانيا والتفويض
الدول الاخرى للقيام بذلك
وسط ملامح التغيير التي تفرض نفسها يوصل
الرئيس الفرنسي اماله في ان يكون جزءا من
اي مفاوضات سلام المستقبليه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وذهب الى حد الحديث عن يا طير
ضمانات امنيه لروسيا الامر الذي اثار غضب
الكثيرين في اوروبا وليس فقط في الشره
المانيا لم تكن حكومتها مستعده للحرب
ناهيك عن القطع المفاجئ للطاقه والتجاره
الروسيه ومع تزايد القلق بشان اعتماد
مماثل على الصين تواجه المانيا الحاجه الى
اعاده تشكيل اقتصادها القائم على التصدير
والمبني على الغاز الروسي الرخيص والتجاره
غير المقيده مع الصين
الحرب في اوكرانيا احدث التغيرات الكبيره
في ميزان القوه التقليدي تغييرات وعلى ما
يبدو لن تقف عند هذا الحاده عصام عبد
السلام العربيه